welcome to this video
round 5 of the knowledge has super
tournament yeah this probably was the
round with them with them yeah most
interesting and most tense chess content
I really have some problem to to do this
video without getting awfully long I'm
to try my best focusing on some key
points otherwise really am I could do it
to our videos of video out of it I'm
going to start with Grisha gutka Stein
dr. Stein um both players on 50%
odka start playing four drawers increase
shop winning two losing two so a funny
tournament and artist I'll actually had
winning chances so in the earlier games
an interesting battle probably so we got
the the star in its French very topical
line and I could start repeating the
line that he had played and I think it
was round three against kayaking where
he was in fact winning but spoiled it at
the end with an end game miscalculation
and we follow this game for quite a
while only here Queen d8 is a new move
not in general new move but deviation he
played had played Queen to h4 with check
in the game against Coyoacan Queen d8
was unexpected and new for Pakistan yeah
and we got a position where were there
five White had some yeah it looked like
somebody taking chances I was able to
watch some of the press conference and
the Grisha said that he was at that
point thinking this should be excellent
for white it looks nice but it's not
clear how to really break through this
happened and
yeah what it looks nice but how actually
do you do you again anywhere let's say I
won f7 both minor pieces here are not
really well placed in that regard
yeah we got an interesting position here
after a three here artist that didn't
need to take he also could play him
Norman move let's say rook g8 and it
does not look like he's got any any
great problems he decided to take and
this is now gets to a somewhat more
complicated position 94 was the obvious
point intending checks and you need to
take it the rook takes now an
interesting position with opposite
colored bishops was on the board very
often the opposite colored bishops are
favored or favoring the attacker and at
first it looks like widest to the
attacker you know with the dark squares
being more accessible but he made this
interesting movie three strong moves
probably that makes sure that the e pawn
is going away and it opens up the long
diagonal foot I want to play against g2
and after the capture Queenie fibers
played yeah white can also take with the
Queen but then there's got less discount
play Bishop coming to c6 joining the
action black seems to be ok here it's
not really anything great that what has
after that it looks like white has some
initiative but it's not really clear how
to learn to make any headway and the
problem it seems was according to the
press conference that gree shocked yeah
being an optimistic player I guess
thought that he still was holding an
advantage here I mean he's gotten his
one porn down and it looks like he's got
some initiative but probably it's only
good enough to to be equal he however
played the aggressive move c4
pushing this pawn trying to get another
unit into their tech probably but at the
Sun simply took it and yeah with a kind
of show me attitude
what do you have for this now I think
white still would have had enough
compensation in case of Queen d6 this is
at least what the engine Houdini in this
case is pointing out this is directly
trying to get to the e7 square like with
this and this is in fact not so easy for
black to prevent he can has numerous
ways to to equalize with the counter
tachyon g2 but it does not seem to be a
leading to an advantage quite some some
interesting lines like this the sec and
this is enough counter play to secure it
wrong um but Grisha didn't do that and
as you probably can imagine he was
intentional already and the following
the following moves will move 33 up to
move 40 pretty much if you look at it
with them with an engine are very very
questionable all of those moves but you
got to understand that they are not
playing perfectly with very little time
on the clock especially if you look at
three shocks time management I know it's
it's a mess and he probably yeah it's
it's it's a logical consequence of not
having enough time to make those
mistakes here here's one one very
specific case look at the eight and
especially this this trade um after
Queen the Asia probably would have led
to a draw yeah if we look at this King
g7 Jack who in here and this is going to
be a draw by perpetual check you can
continue this line with black running
running out of the whole thing here
- all the way to you forum but the
question is if can you still win this
Hanks this hangs Queen III threatened
it's just difficult the computer is
totally unimpressed and gives it zero
zero zero so that's probably a perpetual
guy plate king h1 doe and this turns out
to be an unlucky decision king f7 route
36 yeah this was all pretty pretty
plausible we should perform yeah
also okay Queen a5 now by now black has
two pawns up really and White has no no
attack in the sense that it would give
him a win or anything it's just a matter
of trying to to get a perpetual
somewhere after Queen f5 here it was
Greece look smooth we had very little
time on the clock by now artists and
also was low and he played the rooks is
six and this in fact should have lost
the game and I'm actually a bit
surprised that after Stein didn't see
the winning continuation you must have
Merkel miscalculated something because
it is pretty easy to see for a strong
Jam ya hear of the move that wins for
black is not going to say it maybe you
can find it yourself
pause the video okay I'm giving the move
now rook takes tree to which is one here
and it's not that difficult as the lines
are very straight forward King takes
Queen g4 is very easy to see picks up
the rook and then it's three points plus
White's King is totally out in the open
so an easy win and after this you can
take with check white moves the King no
choice and then Bishop d7 is just a
deadly pin White has no check in this
position
yeah well the meaningless rooks is seven
but that's it and this means black will
take the exchange at least back and
then it's such a three parts of so this
would have one rook takes she to didn't
play it the King g6 was played and now
rooks e7 was played also not the best
but they had seconds right
so it's Roxy fall was stronger but okay
rooks e7 and here again black could have
won with the move Queen e4 which is in
fact less obvious in a way that rook g2
but the strong side of this move is that
it prepares Bishop to b7 activating the
bishop on the long diagonal and this
also seems to be winning for black he
played e5 though which is quite
understandable move and puts thorns on
dark squares which make sense in
combination with the light square bishop
so then it also takes away squares from
the white bishop it's a strategically
founded move but Queenie 4 was just
better from creed reasons yeah it seems
that after that blacks advantage is
still there but it is difficult because
he get does not get a good coordination
of the pieces after check these moves
white is getting a pawn back and this
was very hard for black to prevent and
with all things happening now on one
side it's it's pretty much to draw they
in fact got to got a position like that
where a Queen trade even was played and
here you don't need to be too 792 to
draw the game in fact they agreed to a
draw right here you have you got
opposite colored bishops with the no
idea whatsoever to to win um yeah a
somewhat disappointing end of the game
for artists fine who really should have
won I mean Luke takes you to especially
as a move that it's not very difficult
to see yeah I mean yet almost two
minutes on the clock and it's pretty
much the first move you look at I mean
I'm not quite sure why why he discarded
that I
I didn't see all of the press conference
okay
he could have easily won two games to
this point and heat the tournament but
okay a draw is not a bad result if you
would have said before the game to ml
which you want to draw against tooth
against Grisha Pro say okay but the way
it it went there was chances for more
okay the next games viddler coyoacán um
this will be the first one and it wasn't
any an interesting game to be honest but
I need to cut things somewhere they had
this um reversed maroc C point sulla
again playing an on e for opening night
f3 c4 and he went for this plan with a
quick before which is one of the
interesting ways to play it is why this
kind of reversed maroc see if white is
playing it in slowly like d3 and no
91-92 whatever
yeah 91 is ridiculous but 92 like black
is doing in the Monocacy but very often
the the white player is just you having
an extra tempo which is almost
meaningless so you have no advantage at
the white whatsoever saw this before
plan is interesting the general idea is
that if black takes on before you take a
five
yeah Knight takes is very obvious and
after Bishop takes even there there is
not 65 this funny trick based on the
deuce position of the bishop so white
with V form manages to to trade off and
an a pawn for C pawn and this is the
foundation for White's claim for an
advantage it's not terribly much but
it's an interesting way to play yeah and
after a couple of moves I think really
if we look at this sweet Allah really
had reached a position that can only be
described as yeah the the kind of
position you aim for when you play like
this yeah he has gotten this this
position here on c5 for the bishop and
all this is not looking too active yeah
if we look a bit further to this
position should we shut down put this on
the bottom to this position after e3 and
route d6 I think here we come to the
critical point and yeah here you played
the most Age 3 verses which is not so
clear what it is doing ok the back rank
yeah I'm quite aware of that tries to
make some some room for the king some
lift um it still seems that the the
midnight edge for the the
straightforward solution would have been
very interesting it's not so clear what
black should do here as Knight f5 is
really quite a substantial threat yeah
black can just a check yeah that's true
but chappy look at this what exactly is
black doing next c6 is just hanging you
cannot easily move the knight yeah like
that for example quite embarrassing the
smooth white is just winning immediately
and yeah this is just very bad for black
rook t1 check certainly not the defense
yeah the engine gives a 97 that's pretty
much the only possible move and after
that here why does just a pawn up for no
particular compensation on the black
side I mean this is certainly good for
what not sure why you discarded Knight
edge for after Age 3 I think the worst
is over white still retains an advantage
but it does not seem to have that that
German big proportions then it could
have been with Knight age 4 yeah here it
is still somewhat better but
it's nothing it's nothing particularly
particularly great yeah in fact after a
couple of moose here it fizzled out to a
draw chata camper here they got to a
perpetual so night h4 was a was a good
possibility here force wiggler and one
thing I should briefly show because it
was quite interesting
instead of rookie six year black head
the move Knight d4 which also explains
my cylinder head plate III right
afterwards and ninety four would have
been pretty good equalizing move I think
it's not it's not totally equal but very
difficult to see how check cactus this
kind of line it's very forced and well
white retains an advantage but it it
certainly should be possible to hold the
position
yeah well it's not fun to play but sleep
probably better than what happened or
what could have happened in the game
yeah a draw here in this in this game
and this was relatively speaking the
least interesting one of the round
okay the next game I'm going to look at
is quite sure Geary to panel yeah and to
give replaying 1.e4 yeah he's mixing his
opening move some I always I must admit
I always have the feeling if he plays
one avoids it sometimes looks a bit
funny sorry if I'm very frank there
because he's such a strong player but I
always feel that that would defy you
feels more at home or Knight f3 this
kind of closed stuff with e4 sometimes
it feels like he does not have the the
kind of right feel for some positions
especially in the Sicilian yeah to power
of played that and the open Sicilian or
the Sicilian and they got Rosen and the
classical so you know with Bishop g5 is
called the
the rouser attack and in fact this kind
of classical Sicilian at this position
here where white as the main choice
between the bishop moves here mostly
it's about those three moves Bishop c4
Bishop g5 it should be too with Bishop
g5 nowadays being the most critical this
is in fact the line that from the black
side is somewhat out of fashion at top
level but it's not completely clear why
that is in fact it is a line that would
be very interesting to to to play on on
an amateur or a semi-professional level
like the mid-range kind of level because
it leads a very complicated play and
it's somewhat forgotten compared to many
other lines people are all everybody
knows something about the knight of
nowadays but ask them about some subtle
move Odyssey and in the browser
difficult yeah and we see that quickly
get one main position of this opening
here a4 played by by Gary nowadays
there's also the most f3 played here
quite often trying to get to a position
that is similar to them to the English
attack with a later g4 only that the
bishop is on g5 in fact sometimes white
even voluntarily retreats the bishop and
gets it English to take a tempo down
which at first such a sharp position
sounds weird but on the other hand
blacks setup with Bishop d7 is not the
most perfect as well so every an
interesting way to play for white may be
somewhat easier to play in a way than f4
ya now b5 is played black is coming with
this before threat attacking before in
the long run and we get this this
transformation here with the pawn
structure damaged on on f6 note that
black cannot take with the Queen which
is important after a 5
d 595 blankets pretty much toast
so GF must be played and now King B 1
plate I try to briefly look at the 3d of
this and basically gave up because at so
many different lines that both sides can
play the the main thing here in this
position is that young White's position
is some it's very often centered around
one idea and this is to play f4 f5 at
the right moment what white ideally
wants to achieve is to to play a5 and
force black to play 65 under the most
unfavourable circumstances possible so
that after f5 a move of the e pawn 95
becomes possible you want to fight yeah
for this d5 square by pushing f5 and to
be honest there are not so many other
other plans here in the game it was
quite funny because if we look at this
you know those moves you Queenie 1h one
night c1 yeah prophylactic move but
white is absolutely ages away from ever
playing f5 and actually forcing black in
some way to move the pawn so I must say
I don't really know this opening 12
lifelong player of close games I just
sometimes play one e4 and blitz games
for fun and I really don't know what I'm
doing sometimes I'm not totally sure and
at which point this goes wrong for Geary
but around here yeah we get to position
look at this the white is just passive
he has no active plan he can play a 5 at
some point but what exactly is it
achieving as you never ever going to
force black to play e5 and even if he
plays e5 the knight 1 c1 is ages away
from jumping to d5
the whole position here already is very
comfortable for black he's got two
bishops the deficits in the pawn
structure and not really felt white
cannot really attack the weaknesses and
white is basically without a clear plan
and yeah we couldn't continue for for a
couple of moves and we see black
improving all the way
Bishop to a6 a5 a4 and white is
basically mostly shuffling yeah and it's
really hard for me to suggest some
improvement the real problem is also why
does not have any meaningful bond break
you cannot ever play e5 and f5 is
mentioned it's not really helping
anything or not improving anything and
yes you form this is also a tricky move
I'm not sure if this really helps
after c4 to power played King f8 which
wasn't bad but there also was a more
forceful way to play Queen a6 which is
quickly pointed out by the computer now
c4 is attacked how do you protect this
if you look at b3 there is the move
Queen 8 yeah this is just a very sad
before cannot be protected
yeah Knight b5 is probably what needs to
be done yeah and then after Queen c6
black is also clearly for choice
something like that
for example jack is just not looking
good yeah King a1 black can't castle
quite funny on you 30 but it's just
strong c4 hangs and b3 is punished by
then capture and then Bishop c2 just not
not great I mean not great white is flat
out using Queen a6 was a bit stronger
than King f8 but black still retains a
very favorable position
a couple of more moves we got to got to
this position like took it and now
finally kiri played f5 and he basically
said he just wanted to do something I
mean not trying to sit to play a sit and
wait game the the the bad thing about
the movements is just losing after rupee
five from like it's just attacking e4
and there is really no good way to to
defend it
Ruki to assess even more disastrous than
what he played here black can just take
you know takes takes and the queen is
all that you want look yeah this was
played in the game and now the next move
is really mysterious if I say this is a
totally mysterious move to part of
obviously
Kalp she miscalculated something he
played King h8 and what he could have
done is d5 and after that white is
basically exploding him there is there
was absolutely nothing to defend the
position probably this was his his issue
I'm not sure taking and then black takes
and plays oops e8 it's just just very
bad this position Queen b3 for example I
can take Czech rook takes you take free
and then take a form black has various
ways to win not clear why d5 wasn't
played he played King to age 8 and ya
know after Knight f3 which is not very
surprising the rook is hanging and yeah
I mean you can he took here on on a5 but
you can try to to move it away but after
96
they are you doing next threatening here
and the capture is also not very great
this is hanging and blacks King
especially assessed in a totally bad
position I King edge eight is really
mysterious move you know here here black
has just lost so we took on a five and
after Knight takes e5 f e5 and ninety
six white is also totally winning well
so King age eight basically instead of
winning the game
yeah gave it away a very mysterious very
mysterious course of this game yeah
black was trying to sort of irritate
give you a total of was trying to
irritate give me a bit he just took
everything and there is no threat
whatsoever can there was somewhat
turning tips along the way but this was
a very clear way to win now Queen age
six meet and threatened chat and after
this move the power of resigned yeah I
cannot take oops
checkmate because of the simple made and
there are King g7 check this is also not
going to end particularly she well it's
their major maybe this is noisier Bishop
pigs checkmates and April let's meet
yeah I mean white will probably made
some how well the computer is giving him
eight and five okay I'll take that yeah
a disastrous came early for T'Pol off he
could have relatively easily won the
game with with this d5 move and I mean
he had twenty seven minutes on the clock
instead he played King h8 which after
Knight f3 really traps the rook and it's
it's pretty much lost right after that
so very strange thing to happen yeah he
simply does not seem to be in any
any good shape he wasn't in good shape
at that candidates and countenances skin
in April I think it was and this does
not seem to be any better
so quite a quite a bad game for him
yeah curious back on Twitter on fifty
percent with this game he or he was very
dissatisfied in the press conference
which I understand I mean basically he
was gifted the point in a way he had
played in a really passive fashion
against so you're not the the kind of
chess you really want to play against
this opening which requires aggressive
play and he was pretty much totally
outplayed only the pile of strange
decisions really am I gave him the point
all right
this was to Paul of playing back against
kiri and the next game I'm going to look
at is chronic cat wanna and I must say
this is a longer game but I don't want
to look at the opening face to too long
yeah chronic is going from the g3 line
here which pretty much gives black a
wide choice as I mentioned in a formal
video I like this line for black at this
karana is playing here this quick Queen
c7 I'm directly playing against the
point one funny point being that b3 d5
is actually a good line which might look
funny to you but it is really a good
line I just want to show briefly that
this for example is not working at all
Jack think I've shown that more than
once in a video but I've simply simply
like them like this there was motifs
white cannot take on d5 relief and this
makes it an attractive line yeah calmly
complete Queen d3 avoiding that and this
is a somewhat rare remove but he's
always some
he's very well known for his new ideas
in openings 96 castles interesting 95
looks totally obvious but it's not so
great after Queen e3 after that night
see for Queen e7 is definitely not what
black ones getting a somewhat bad
structure with the weak pawn him so 95
not great he just played d6 and b3 and
now we sort of have a normal-looking
position out of the symmetrical
english-only with this funny Queen moves
Queen d3 and Queen c7 inserted karana
now goes for forcing line with 94 which
trades off quite some pieces yeah
the way Kramnik is playing I think is
quite interesting he could have taken of
course which is the most obvious way to
play after Bishop c3 Bush and age 6
Bishop a1 bishop f8 you should f6 the
position is only very marginally better
for white probably probably very close
to equal
he played 95 whatever and this makes it
a bit more difficult for corona in fact
this whole sequence is rather
complicated but I don't want to look at
it very deeply the funny moopheus Bishop
e3 just eschewing the capture of the of
the rook here and they're just thoughts
black okay I'm going to get through
anyway rook b8 Bishop sorry rook a 1 in
fact after this is hanging and a7
essaying
and white is better yeah I think this
was pretty much
just good play by both sides here they
captured a couple of enhance and get got
this this this endgame position well
white is slightly better because of the
better piece activity in fact after a
later c5 here this this pawn pressure
here on the six letter to yes
transformation where white at the end
one opponent is having fun is what what
he won and this the oldest is really
complicated and and interesting to look
at the mostly kramnik I mean Cara wanna
as mostly just sitting in the best
conference and saying nothing but Crum
neck is giving a lots of lines that he
had had considered and this was a rather
complicated part of the game but if I go
into detail here we are we're not
getting anywhere I want to get to the
endgame they had seen all the trades and
we see that white has retained an extra
pawn but black is rather active rook and
Bishop attack the pawn on v3 which is
only defended at the mode by White's
forces and it's not clear that white can
actually win with the extra corn Kramnik
is is trying hard he went for g5 in fact
it looks that it doesn't know that it's
not like that all by am by buddhini but
I feel I still feel that is a very human
movement and rather normal as white is
trying to yeah fight form for an
invasion route for the king and if we
continue but we see that chromic didn't
find any way forward really it was a bit
of shuffling not that much shuffling I
mean they could have done this for quite
longer one adhered here roopd to with
rook to Kramnik is really saying okay
take the pawn right
you know if he--if like is not taking a
white I might do something like group
age to h7 something like that or switch
over to a - I don't know he's basically
returning the phone and says okay I'm
going to activate the through t5 and all
this was played to get the King into the
game this is very important of course in
the endgame
you should always try to use your King
to the fullest activated as much as
possible as it is just a great an
attacking piece the King channel this is
totally normal and here exactly here at
move 50 if we get to the decisive point
of the game isn't this a total draw you
might ask yourself yeah in fact it is
but in this concrete position black has
to play the only move and the only move
from in this position is King f8 it
meant I mean obviously there's King 8 +
f8 right and where do you go
Kawana played King e8 and not King King
f8 and the the problem is King f8 is a
draw and King yet is losing it's just
like that King f8 is a draw and this is
because after King f6 which is the only
really move to try black a scheme is
check and here the White King cannot in
any way move forward
it just has to drop back and after rook
v3 we have a repetition and white is not
making any inroads here absolutely not
yeah let's say you can can go any way I
can go here still give this check and go
back there is absolutely no way forward
and what's the difference let's look at
the difference can wanna play this and
after King f6 back from Nick who
probably couldn't really believe what
was happening yeah why does attacking
the pawn and the problem is it's not not
just dead after the check and this is
for challenge the was played back her
wanna King g7 was played yeah it's here
and we see the main difference with the
King on e8 this g7 square is suddenly
available for the King and he now has
entered the position and now black isn't
is not a sword of Zeus money what are
you doing here you cannot really give up
the pawn on a3 and if you do that I mean
if you if you cover it I'm sorry
Group III white will really win the pawn
and this it turns out is a winning
endgame in fact quite to my surprise and
most spectators surprised after King g7
a koala actually already resigned he was
formally so disgusted yeah what
disgusted that he played this this
really silly King Hayden
so that he really wanted to do to not
see any more of it but in fact it was a
bit of a shame I think that he didn't
continued a bit Kramnik would have
certainly found the win but it's I think
always good for the spectators to to
really understand why is the other side
was a black site actually resigning I
can show you a sample line how it could
could have gone rogue p3 King g6 King
evade and you can do various things but
I just want to show some general way how
a black can how white can actually win
pushes the pawn something something
along these lines
yeah let's say he said not the only way
but one way
kingi form and after King g4 the problem
is black has no checks from the back
needs to man up there needs to protect
a3 advisors to threatening to push the
Jeep on so like can can wait for one or
two moves out but at some point he needs
to to switch the f-22 to this
from the back and after that after Luke
a3 King in seven this is a winning
endgame and I think the the only thing
that really must be done is to play the
exact exactly right move here it's not
very difficult but still I probably
think most of you will do this move
rather rather intuitively and it's it's
quite clear that rook f3 must be played
as this is simply blocking blacks King
to join in on the defense and after this
White has the totally winning
who can't game we can continue this for
a bit King g5 rook g1 check yeah
something something like that King King
just have no g7 sorry looked at my notes
wrong about King g7 doesn't make any
sense yeah yeah we can get something
like this
yeah just very very well known and here
black can try this to cover f8 and yeah
now the winning procedures is well known
is this thing called building building a
bridge actually not here right because
King f7 as possible let me briefly look
how it is is done most easily check here
first
yeah you should yeah you should check
here first actually
this is this is easy King back and now
we got three giving the check on the
hypothesis this is easiest easiest
stupid okay yeah well this is some sort
of tragic end to this game too for
caruana I mean he had defended all the
time and it wasn't much fun certainly
and then right at the end he's stumbling
and losing the game this is in fact a
similar what happened to him in the in
Dortmund last year when he had defender
the worst position really a tremendously
well for a long time and then at the
right at the end he he did some
miscounting and lost it lost the game
very comparable situation and very
important loss in the tournament he had
+2 score excellent score now down to +1
while Kramnik is now joining or not
joining he's taking the lead with the +2
score two wins and no loss
okay so game of the day and this is the
game cards Neronian we are already on
the 40 minute mark in this video which I
sort of expected because there was too
much content in the games to just go
through them like so quickly that you
don't get any any benefit from it so
cars Aronian this game is terribly long
I'm going to tell it right away and I
don't want to make too our video so I'm
going to just look at some some some key
moments we have the Queen's Gambit logos
and funny enough the same opening that
cousin had played just round before with
the black pieces but it's also part of
Aronian opening repertoire and we get a
very sharp position with quick g5 94 and
after 92
took on g3 yeah and here there is a
novelty I guess at least that my gaiter
pace didn't have the
Carson is playing them with F takes G 3
not a totally illogical move
I mean it's opening up their file which
makes some sense if you consider that
Black has weakened especially the f5
Square tremendously still it's somewhat
of an untidy move and more like a
dynamic choice than cosmesis normally
playing is very often more going for
form for clarity a form for structures
that are more yeah let's say more
predictable in a way um I think the next
couple of moves are very yeah very
logical in a way they both develop Queen
on f3 Bishop or d3 makes lots of sense
controlling f5 and black is going from
after this for long castling yeah walk a
short castling does not make much sense
and why not cast along here um yeah you
get a really really complicated position
now a forest plate they are trying to
use the a pawn as a battering ram and
it's it's going forward all the way to
a6 yeah very weird structures now rising
here black has a choice um I probably
would have yeah I'm not sure not sure I
mean he played Ronia play group h2 8
which is fine I think I would have gone
for b6m I really wouldn't have liked to
let white take on b7 but this is always
an interesting decision should you play
this kind of move against those advances
and sort of keep your structure intact
but on the other hand a6 is a terribly
annoying porn you always think that okay
well Queen on b7 I'm going to be
checkmated right and it's it can happen
yeah maybe I will still preferred that
but
I really droopy aid and king of two
first king b8 ruby one yeah
and now the capture so he hell out wide
to take on this Apple and this is of
course very well known defensive measure
just let the other side take the pawn
near King and use this pawn as a shield
yeah because all right obviously cannot
take the his own porn yeah and that is
okay I'm not saying that p6 was any
better I just wanted to explain that
this is the alternative which also has
some dangers yeah
what you also should do sometimes it's
just County it's equal material but the
b7 pawn in many cases can get lost
especially if we consider some endgame
situation where the point cannot be
supported the whole position now gets
very complicated Queen before it's
played activating the Queen King G 1
will be to invading yeah the night did
not really have a great square and on
everyone there is some ideas later to
activate it notice g4 maybe at 93 FF 5
terribly terribly arrows that I'm
drawing this kind of idea yeah black
plate f5 directly controlling the
important f5 square root a 5 this looked
interesting looking at the poor poor Nia
and intending to to double on the FL or
maybe go here in the right moment and
our Bishop a force play and this kind of
position is really a bit mind-boggling
and I I really cannot claim that I
understand what's going on because it
looks a in a way so random
cavil play group c5 it turns out that
this isn't terribly great news the
computer suggest Queen f2 here
and actually likes white what is clear
if we look at the game continuation that
this this is probably better queen f2
but how exactly to assess the position I
find they're really difficult to do
black should probably play Queen to
before and not trade the Queen trade
yeah it's not a very very lucky decision
as those pieces are really somewhat
unstable and it's not easy to use them
white also sometimes very quickly going
with rook a one and taking a seminal
it's not a good idea but after Queen
have to black can retreat after that
let's probably look a six needed to be
played and then let's say yeah there are
many ideas but let's say f4 and this is
a total mess I'm really not I'm not
clear I'm not sure what what's going on
here look at this for example and we
should be five now what's going on here
no idea this is hanging this is an idea
it's a total mess but Queen f2 is
probably a better than what Carson
played he played rook c5 and yeah this
does not lead to much Luke f8 covering
f5 and now h3 is played yeah here in
this position I was watching the
broadcast but and short was already he
had a very good feel for the position
and he's thought that yeah madness is
losing the threat here not really having
any idea and h3 was a move way said he
does not get the idea at all
I mean I actually get the idea maybe but
it's not working I thought that maybe
Knight h2 moving the Queen and Knight f3
was the idea trying to have not a
freedom to e5 right trying to improve
the old principle improve your worst
piece which is the knight on f1 and
probably but the thing is some it
probably is yeah it is a plan but not a
plan that
we really on really realized yeah rook
f6 Knight h2 SS mentioned the idea and
now rook DMF a displayed the computer
and this position points out the funny
move through d2 d6 not quite sure what
this is doing I mean probably something
similar than the other move to move
trying to cover this and prepare an ID
form but yeah I'm not not quite sure how
a human should find all those subtleties
the black is definitely in good shape
after this move I mean yeah Knight e4 is
coming and it's not so clear what white
White's plan is especially the rook on
c5 looks a bit stranded still I must
admit that I really don't I really don't
feel qualified to to give a good
judgement here the computer is just
liking black yeah with a very distinct
advantage but it's still a total mess I
mean I can just read the evaluation but
it's not like I can actually explain to
you what's going to happen um
it's it looks good for black and also
what Aronian did also looks good for
black if we continue here Knight e4 and
here probably Carvin needed to take on
d5 per team with unclear plane still
unclear play but he played rookie - we
should briefly look at routine 5 huh
and let's say this - and this this seems
to be quite ok I'm quite okay for white
stone rookie 2 was played and after this
it's probably very critical Queen 83
yeah attacking the bishop and there is
really no other with white now needs to
take it on before and after this we see
that some day the F file is opened up
and you really get a better feel
here as white your king is in trouble
your night is not good yeah this looks
very serious
Queenie one nc6 this allows this further
bishop maneuver to improve the bishop
and look at the f1 square and here black
is an excellent shape really it's still
however very difficult okay five and now
Queen b3 which is very understandable
you want to get out of the pin however
in this position probably lost them was
one situation where Aronian was very
near to a winning that's in the in this
game in this particular situation he
could have played h5 and this is in fact
a very important move it's difficult
though of course a difficult but it is
good because it takes away this
important square of the night the night
has now no active deployment nike form
is about the only way to do it and it
was difficult to see at this point that
you need to play h5 exactly this which
this situation but it probably was the
the best the best um moving the position
and the best points to play h5 after
Queen b3 Queen a1 the situation is still
very good for black but it's not totally
clear if we look at we should be fine
which is the top suggestion of the of
the engines I understand that black is
better but I'm not so totally convinced
that he will win easily if we look at
this the rook moves and then a6 this is
what the computers want to play yeah
fortifying this Bishop then the problem
is if we look at this for example yeah
this is happening this kind of stuff
um the issue is is this really winning
it looks great for black at first but
the night suddenly is jumping into the
action and I am not totally sure that
white should win this we look at this
black is clearly better I know but is it
a win I don't know I'm not totally
totally sure that it is a total and
clear win it it's certainly the case if
we compare this just imagine yeah
why does not have 94 and yeah magically
this pawn is on h5 then white is done
yeah absolutely done as the night is
never going to get activated any more
and then it's it's basically like two
points that won't be seven faults and
like as a and C porn well this three
against two is basically not counting
and yeah probably this is also very very
good but it was easier if black would
have played h5 our Liam Jack Queen d1s
what post played and it seems that this
gives away all advantage in one move
unfortunately here for Aronian yeah I
got the straight and rupee one and now
we see a very important issue biases
Bishop going to go it wanted to go to b5
trying to I'm sorry
trying to support the Queen side but
this you cannot really do any more I
mean you want to go here really yeah
with tempo and another temple and all of
a sudden why does an excellent shape
black absolutely needs to prevent Nagi
for so we needed to drop back to h5 yeah
and okay here not chief voice is an
unlucky idea don't want that so white
had to basically play
and what he did a bit pawn to g4 so that
this is a further activation Bishop back
and now the bishop is inside of the pawn
chain and not outside like it was could
have been on b5 yeah yeah White has rook
a1 even the knight on h2 is the only
serving one purpose covering f1 but this
is a very important purpose
yeah and white after this we'll get the
a pawn yeah um again now we come to the
next critical situation aronia by now
certainly assembled unnerved it was down
to 1 minute 40 he played look f2 and
it's not clear to me why he didn't take
only 7 it is looking dangerous yeah but
it still seems to be much better than
what was played why it can take and we
can continue this Lion King b6 and maybe
he was very much irritated that I mean
Blacky Aronian that this pin is in
effect but Bob Bishop d7 is some solving
this issue I guess the computer is
giving this he has total total equality
which I personally still doubt because
at least in a practical game white here
is much easier to play also considering
the way the game went I still think that
counsel would have been quite would have
had quite good chances to do something
here but it's clearly the better option
for black compared to the game in the
game yeah he gave away the pawn and sort
of now tried to get it back if we look
at what happens
can we get somewhat worse version of all
that and see now after a couple of moves
the route gets traded anyway but now in
the meantime White has activated his
forces enormous Lee and when now has a
very very dis
advantage in fact the activity
immediately leads to a porn loss here of
the h-bomb and around him it looked like
might should simply win but it it still
took a long time and some of those moves
were still yeah were not clear to also
to the commentators for here for example
Nigel short who is doing the commentary
on the official website he had suggested
rook to d6 and in fact this looks very
strong to me the idea being to play rook
d8 setting up a pin on the bishop and
this looked like a very strong
continuation if we just consider for a
moment this and black is trying to
activate you like the sinking activation
to the utmost yeah and here white has a
good winning plan and I think a pretty
convincing one he can use the King now
like that and will win in the long run
yeah getting this back and at the end
the G pawn in combination with the pin
will decide the game Rock d6 was a very
strong alternative rook h7 did not look
that pointed now I'm black got some
activity and here we come to the yeah
the phase of the game where it would be
very interesting to look at it even
deeper but I didn't have the time to do
to look at it properly because this is
the kind of situation where Carlton is
playing excellently really um he has not
made the best of his chances so far I
guess but he's still not going to be
totally irritated of playing bad news
now he's just pressing on and on and we
see after a couple of more moves which
if you look at it just superficially
looks like
awfully he got to a situation check yeah
or even going back here moves later
check yeah here he got to a situation
which is now totally winning for him
yes played in a way that the king is now
on b2 not having any irritating counter
play against the upon and with the next
move Knight h5 is threatening to to
enter on f7 which is totally deadly you
know like taking and taking his one
thread on night h7 to g5 just grabbing
the pawn yeah here why does winning I
mean maybe the whole thing around here
even with him not playing this route d6
move as suggested by short maybe white
is winning in the long run anyway but I
couldn't really am I couldn't really
check that with the time available if if
this is really the case in the game he
slowly had pushed Aronian back and came
to this after which black probably must
take yeah I cannot allow the night to
enter and now we got a rook endgame
which is really a completely winning and
it still took about Aronian still have
four on but the the pawns are are too
strong check-check
some still some tricks that Aronian got
into the game here captain Daniels not
making any any mistake here anymore
King g5 and now the King supports the
h-bond still continue the bit rooks e6
yeah here g5 was was an interesting
moment when III is giving at least some
counter play if we look at this this
looks quite annoying
yeah what can can take and promote the
computer in fact gives a nice evaluation
you like +20 seeing that white will
promote but this is still exercise
exercise success relatively speaking for
black who can fight at least fight on
yeah thousand didn't go for that he just
took c6 Chandler went to to this end
game which is really a very simple win
DHS just check it's just jack it's just
decisive check yeah the typical
procedure yes why this blocking the
checksum yeah here in fact here Aronian
resigned the game yeah a very
disappointing loss for him certainly you
had he had a very nice position around
to move 30 if we look back around here
here white looks looks really in bad
shape I mean maybe if you are investing
more time to find the absolute best
continuations you can prove why really
win for black it looks it looks
excellent
but this Quinn d1 really at the very
least here he had sport is advantage and
after that it's a fairly typical
situation when you have spoiled your
advantage and you had an advantage that
you were aware of right sometimes you're
spoiling too much and you don't really
know that you had it yeah like there was
some hidden possibility that you you
didn't really seem and well you only see
it after the game and okay okay stupid
that I didn't do that but if you really
have a great position and you spoil it
and you see that you've spoiled it then
it's very often not just a draw that you
you spoil it to it then you pretty much
very often play another inaccurate move
was some some blunder even to to lose
the game
and this is in a way happened here and
it was also generally speaking a very
very tough position to play I mean
really really not something that you
can't call a symbol or anything it was
very complicated stuff so this means
after this round we have chronic leading
of the tournament with a plus to score
and following is some yeah karana now
with +1 and the world champion Magnus
Carlsen with this first win of this
tournament to be honest my money is
still on cards to win the whole thing is
just very very stable and can I think
easily get in like two more wins and the
remaining four mounts and win the whole
thing yeah very interesting round with
much content so we got somewhat close
somewhat over the 1 hour mark and I
think this is this is fair I hope you
enjoyed the coverage I'll be back I
think tomorrow is yet another round
round 6 and yeah I look forward to that
I do too yeah let's meet again with
round 6 coverage tomorrow thanks for
watching